i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight our
interview with a loudoun county virginia
father last night over what he alleged
happened to his daughter in a bathroom
forced the school system to respond
today we're going to bring you that
update plus you'll hear from the parents
who were there with unique insight and a
massive media cover-up involving a
supreme court justice and why is kamala
twisting history for
native peoples of course it's raymond
arroyo he has it in scene and unseen but
first
the biden
who stole christmas
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
and with the holidays coming up you
might be wondering if gifts you plan to
buy will arrive on time
well let me explain
supply chains essentially mean
how we make things
and how the material and parts get
delivered to factory a factory so we can
manufacture things
and manufacture them here
how we move things
how a finished product moves from a
factory to a store to your home
oh hi um
thank the good lord that we have joe
biden as president to state the obvious
doesn't this sound like a seventh grade
book report explaining what a supply
chain
and he offered a simple solution by the
way
what if we strongly encourage the ports
and companies to operate 24 7.
the night hours are critical for
increasing the movement of goods because
highways highways are less crowded than
eve at night
so by increasing the number of late
night hours of operation and opening up
for less crowded hours when the goods
can move faster today's announcement has
the potential to be a game changer
wait a second
is he saying and i guess
the roads
are less crowded in the middle of the
night you're kidding me who knew
the truth is though strongly encouraging
24 7 operations it doesn't help when
they don't have the workers to
physically move the freight from one
container
to the other container now one terminal
that did allow for overnight
working from 3 a.m to 7 a.m reports
that it still had
zero deliveries even it did go into the
wee hours of the morning
well guess what you pay people to stay
off the job and shocker
they'll stay off the job it's funny how
that works
now combine all this with soaring
inflation and you really have a total
mess on your hands
well couldn't say the angle didn't try
to warn you back in may
last week after that abysmal jobs report
biden tried to tell us that the economy
remember was going in the right
direction
well now that narrative has totally been
blown up today's inflation number shows
us just how wrong biden was
and we obviously didn't need a stimulus
package earlier in the year if you don't
want to listen to the angle well listen
to democrat economist larry summers
there is a fiscal theory that looks at
the ultimate consequences of
deficits
that is flashing
a a red a red alarm if you look at
houses if you look at used cars if you
look at commodities if you look at labor
shortages if you look at businesses
reporting uh price increases signs are
of inflation uh
starting to break out
why does janet yellen still have her job
and sure enough biden's people were
wrong yelling on down
the inflation that they saw that they
said was transitory wasn't
and we learned today that year-over-year
price inflation in september was the
highest it's been since january
1991.
okay i graduated from law school in 1991
that was a long time ago gas is now up
42 percent steak 22 egg prices rose
nearly 13 don't you wish you kept that
old clunker by the way used car prices
jumped 24
so the prediction from biden's own team
when seeing all this in its totality
is that heating bills
will rise 54 this winter
and their answer by the way is to double
down on climate change programs and
government spending that will only drive
these prices higher
and even if your grandmother risks i
don't know dying of hypothermia joe says
this is no time to be short-sighted
we need to take a longer view though
that invest in building greater
resilience to withstand the kinds of
shocks we've seen
over and over
year in and year out whether it's the
pandemic
extreme weather
climate change it also means companies
throughout the supply chain like
maritime air freight and trucking
companies reduce their carbon emissions
and help to meet our climate change
goals
translation
if they pass this massive spendo rama
their friends are going to get fat
contracts to produce green products in
china
that ultimately no one really wants here
even as china will continue to burn coal
and ultimately build and grow its
economy get richer
meanwhile
what about those christmas gifts
based on everything being announced
today yeah can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee
no guarantees in life the grinch has
nothing on these people the fact is the
bidet administration has broken our
economy and now they plan to make things
worse by ramming through trillions more
in spending
and get this the feds took in record
amount in tax revenues last fiscal year
but now they want to raise your taxes
because the monster always has to be fed
they took in four trillion dollars
unfortunately for the rest of us though
the press refuses to report and chooses
instead to distort
today cnn clung desperately to some
polling data that they think shows signs
of hope for biden
the president's standing is a bit
stronger than some other recent polling
suggests 50 percent in our brand new
poll releasing right now approve 49
disapproved so an even split in our
polarized times the biden white house
would say you'd like to be a little
better but that's not so bad
not so bad except for this teeny tiny
little detail
only 25 percent one in four think if the
democrats pass this big bill it's going
to make my life better from day to day
only 25 think that a third say i'd be
worse off 43 say about the same
president has to do a better job selling
how this would impact your life
sell sand in the desert
what a pathetic and lazy analysis of
this situation biden's problem
isn't his lame messaging biden's problem
is his ideas will only make life harder
for the average american it's a
substantive problem
biden's trying to use the coming
christmas shortage as justification for
passing an infrastructure bill but the
truth is exactly the opposite
because the inflation situation is so
severe we cannot afford to be dumping
trillions of dollars in new federal
spending into an overstimulated market
where the workers going to come from
where the supply is going to come from
if you start pumping more money into
this economy right now all you're going
to create is a demand spike that will
cause prices to spiral
and shortages will ultimately get worse
biden's team of nincompoops have it
exactly wrong first you have to get
inflation under control
then and only then
could you maybe start thinking about
increased spending for now inflation not
infrastructure has to be the priority
we're going to go right off the cliff
republicans who voted for it you got to
turn around now all 19 of you now we saw
the same dynamic at play for biden with
the afghanistan withdrawal
now the basic goal getting out of
afghanistan did make sense but they
approached it of course in the most
idiotic manner
and here it may make sense to build more
infrastructure later on but trying to
spend enormous amounts of new federal
money at a time of soaring inflation
will be a catastrophe for us
biden and the democrats are going to be
stealing our children's future
just like the grinch in the middle of
the night slithering around those
presents
taking everything in sight
and unlike the cartoon biden won't see
the folly of his ways or have a change
of heart in the end and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else